[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal local
voici les titres de ce mercredi 1er mars
une réunion publique autour du futur
quartier de la remise à voisins le
bretonneux les premières réflexions sur
l'aménagement des espaces publics était
notamment présenté aux habitants
hier soir 5 milliards d'euros pour les
lycées franciliens la région lance un
plan d'urgence pour les établissements
avec pour objectif notamment d'accélérer
les investissements et la rénovation des
bâtiments
enfin dans ce journal vous découvrirez
une église historique du territoire une
église qui se situait il en cours et qui
fête cette année ses 800 ans nom débute
ce journal avec un mot de politique et
le maintien de la candidature de
françois fillon convoqué le 15 mars par
les juges pour une probable mise en
examen
le candidat de la droite et du centre à
l'élection présidentielle s'est exprimé
ce midi devant les journalistes pour
revenir notamment sur la sphère qui
entoure sa femme
écoutez le nombre de mes amis politiques
et de ceux qui m'ont soutenu à la
primaire et ses quatre millions
d'électeurs parle d'un assassinat
politique
c'est un assassinat en effet mais par ce
déchaînement disproportionnée sans
précédent connu par le choix de ce
calendrier
ça n'est pas moi seulement qu'on
assassine
c'est l'élection présidentielle est
encore peu de réactions d'élus yvelinois
après cette annonce même s'il faut noter
la présence aux côtés de françois fillon
ce midi de la président de la région
ile-de-france valérie pécresse
on retiendra également les propos
d'henri guaino député des yvelines est
candidat à la présidentielle lui aussi
pour lui françois fillon ne peut plus
faire campagne et n'a aucune chance de
l'emporter il aspire je cite être le
recours dans cette élection
enfin à gauche un autre député des
yvelines lui aussi candidat à la
présidentielle et tacle le candidat les
républicains benoît hamon dénonce des
propos d'une incroyable
violence à l'égard des magistrats et de
la justice fin de citation dans le reste
de l'actualité
la commune de voisins-le-bretonneux
organisé hier soir une réunion publique
autour du projet de l'éco quartier de la
remise à projets importants pour la
ville puisque à terme 500 nouveaux
logements seront construits avec
également des nouveaux équipements
publics et des espaces verts
reportage il n'est pas encore question
de logement ni même du début des travaux
la problématique évoquée ce mardi soir
en salle du conseil municipal de
voisins-le-bretonneux portaient
principalement sur l'aménagement des
espaces publics voirie espaces verts ou
gestion des eaux pluviales
une première phase du projet urbain
exposé devant une quarantaine
d'habitants ce sont des premières
esquisses des premières études qui sont
faits par le par les cabinets qui ont
été choisis par l'agglomération et donc
ensuite effectivement va falloir rentrer
dans le détail de tous ces aménagements
c'est ce qu'ils vont pouvoir faire
maintenant qu'ils ont vu le public une
première fois ils vont pouvoir se lancer
dans le bétail l'autre sujet évoqué
durant cette réunion publique
l'aménagement actuel du carrefour entre
la rd 36 et la venue de la pyramide à
proximité du terrain bicross un
carrefour modifié depuis janvier pour
anticiper le futur afflux de véhicules
et qui entraîne des problèmes de
sécurité pour les piétons
nous on est inquiet pour les enfants de
notre quartier qui vont au collège
champollion à pied et qui ont à
traverser ce ce carrefour et qui est
déjà dangereux j'habite juste de côté de
carrefour
je suis très intéressé par les
parce qu'il va s'installer ici
l'organisation du carrefour
l'expérimentation je voulais savoir les
résultats que ça donnait à terme ce sont
500 nouveaux logements qui sont attendus
sur un terrain de 10 ha les premiers
travaux devraient débuter en 2019 un
plan d'urgence pour les lycées
franciliens de près de cinq milliards
d'euros c'est la proposition débattue
dans quelques jours au conseil régional
43 rénovation et près de 269 opération
avec notamment le lancement de chantiers
de construction doivent voir le jour
dans quelle mesure le département des
yvelines est concerné
le point avec ce reportage de wilfrid
richy rénovation extension
reconstruction ou maintenance 100 % des
lycées d'ile-de-france seront l'objet
d'une intervention d'ici 2027
c'est l'engagement pris par valérie
pécresse dans le cadre du plan
pluriannuel d'investissement qu'est ce
qu'on va faire
émincer simple on va doubler le montant
du plan d'investissement dans les lycées
et on va en plus réparer les dégâts
quand il y à des problèmes de
maintenance soit un total de cinq
milliards d'euros sur dix ans dont 1
milliard pour l'entretien du patrimoine
immobilier
donc on va avoir un tableau avec pour
chaque lycée un carnet d'identité un
carnet de santé c'est à dire qu'on aura
une connaissance physique du patrimoine
immobilier et tous ses besoins en termes
d'entretien dans les yvelines le lycée
de la plaine de neauphle à attrape le
lycée 17 mar à maurepas ou encore le
lycée rené descartes à montigny le
bretonneux seront donc rénové autre
enjeu pour la région diviser par deux le
délai de construction des lycées en le
portant à cinq ans ainsi vingt mille
huit cent nouvelles places seront créées
à travers la livraison de 12 lycées
neufs et la réalisation de 23 extension
notamment à mantes-la-ville carrières
sur seine ou encore sartrouville huit
mois d'audit ont été nécessaires pour
élaborer ce plan d'urgence et le constat
est alarmant selon la majorité à la
région un établissement sur trois est
vétuste et la hausse des effectifs n'a
pas été anticipé le débat en séance avec
l'ensemble des élus et programmés les 9
et 10 mars prochains
l'actualité c'est aussi en ce moment le
salon de l'agriculture qui se tient
jusqu'au 5 mars porte de versailles à
paris l'occasion de vous faire découvrir
des acteurs locaux du monde agricole ce
mercredi
zoom sur le premier démonstrateur
d'agriculture urbaine de france les
ferments ville de saint cyr l'école qui
font pousser tomates fraises ou encore
fonds bois sur une ancienne décharge
les particuliers peuvent même loué à des
partielles pour avoir leur propre
potager elle les précisions de patrick
jacques de dixmude et de camille lambert
imaginez une ancienne décharge
transformée en ferme
c'est le pari un peu fou mais réussie de
l'association le vivant et la ville en
2014 elle a créé le premier
démonstrateur d'agriculture urbaine de
france c'est un démonstrateur parce que
sa vocation d'être dupliqué sur d'autres
sites délaissé la particularité c'est
que tout est hors sol par nature même
des sols qui sont qui sont pollués ou
contraint toutes les technologies
agricoles sont développés au dessus du
sol
là vous ou situé dans la zone de
production et ont produit des fraises
des framboises et tomates cerises qu'on
va ensuite en circuit court et c'est
l'intérêt de faire des fermes en ville
c'est de pouvoir alimenter l'ensemble
des populations qui vivent aujourd'hui
la plupart du temps en ville une
ancienne friche de près de 4 hectares
devenu un jardin d'éden
l'hiver les équipes préparent les beaux
jours ils viennent d'aménager la culture
des fraises se fit là il vient protéger
des insectes mais à protéger du vent il
a pas mal de fonctions thermique mais on
a décidé de réinstaller c'est la
première fois qu'on le fasse cette année
un tunnel plastique dessous pour gagner
en précocité et pour
commencer plus tôt dans la saison
avantage du hors sol l'eau qui n'est pas
absorbée par les plantes et récupérer
pour être réinjectés une économie non
négligeable pour cette denrée précieuse
les particuliers peuvent aussi jouer les
apprentis maraîchers depuis 2015 la
ferme en ville s'est lancée dans la
location de jardin si vous souhaitez
louer un jardin vous disposez d'un
morceau de cabanes ou d'une malle en
fonction de l'option vous prenez et
ensuite 50 mètres carrés donc vous avez
deux bacs et demi cela correspond à peu
près à 25 mètres carrés de culture avec
un cours de jardinage par mois une
irrigation automatique qui vous enlève
l'astreinte de l'arrosage ce qui est en
soi un confort qui est pas du tout
négligeable
vous cultivez hors sol du coup vous êtes
en hauteur vous avez moins de vous
blesser et c'est une manière de
sensibiliser le grand public
depuis deux saisons l'intérêt des
citadins pour ce dispositif se manifeste
de plus en plus aujourd'hui 50 % des
abonnés vient de saint germain en laye
boulogne même paris on pense que
l'avenir de l'agriculture
ce sera probablement une filière
multifonctionnel associer des métiers
qui sont complémentaires
à voir à la fois des métiers de service
comme typiquement la location de jardin
et des métiers de production comme ce
qu'on voit ici autour de nous une zone
qui est dédiée à la production
professionnelle pour ensuite vendre
cette production pour pouvoir fournir
les sûrs dont un circuit comme chaque
année la ferme en ville crée des emplois
saisonniers pour s'occuper des cultures
elles produites en moyenne 12 à 13
tonnes de fruits et légumes par an elle
espère arriver à 18h dans quelques
années à saint quentin en yvelines la
semaine de l'emploi et de la formation
se poursuit demain plusieurs rendez vous
sont à noter dans vos agendas notamment
l encours au complexe sportif europe
le matin est organisé un forum emploi
spécial jeunes pour les moins de 26 ans
l'après-midi autres forums cette fois ci
pour les acteurs de l'emploi et de
l'insertion professionnelle enfin un
speed dating se déroule également en
salle du conseil communautaire à trappes
toutes les précisions et les
informations complémentaires sont à
retrouver sur sky1 point fr c'est un
monument peu connu mais historique du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
l'église de saint médard situe à l
encours fête cette année ses 800 ans
l'occasion de vous faire découvrir cet
objet du patrimoine
le romain primitif le tout sur des
images de camille lambert le roi clottey
revient à noyon recevoir une dernière
bénédiction de saint médard saint médard
c'est le nom de l'église du village
d'elancourt l'édifice est dédié à cet
évêque du moyen-âge saint médard qui à
l'époque donc qui a été mis en 456 et
bien et est entre autres le créateur
d'une tradition dite de la rose rose qui
mettait en avant les femmes vertueuses
de l'époque on trouve d'ailleurs dans le
vitrail qui est derrière moi vous dire
et une frise entièrement composée de
roses des motifs floraux sur les vitraux
et sur la clé de voûte des peintures de
la croix pattée de type celtique symbole
de la commanderie de lavilledieu une
preuve de remerciement pour l'aide
apportée lors de la construction la
construction a été commencée au 10ème
siècle pour se terminer au 12e siècle
elle a une particularité c'est que la
construction du 10ème siècle d'annecy a
été bien démarré au début était en forme
18 sud ce qui fait qu arriver à la fin
du xième siècle elle était dans un état
qui ne permettait pas que les 80
paroissiens les 80 élan courtois de
l'époque puisse à fréquenter et c'est
donc sous l'impulsion des chevaliers du
temple que l'église a été terminé au 12e
siècle pour arriver au bâtiment tel que
vous l'avez aujourd'hui
huit cents ans d'histoire sauvegardés
par la ville en 1985 elle a rénové les
murs et landry c'est la voûte en bois de
la nef aujourd'hui l'église conserve sa
fonction de lieu de culte des concerts
ils sont également programmés on referme
ce journal sur une autre découverte
celle d'un métier ancestral taupier qui
se charge d'éliminer les taux pour
conserver les pelouse intacte nous avons
rencontré le plus royal d'entre eux
celui du château de versailles
il nous dévoile les secrets de sa
profession dans ce reportage dans leur
langue est la taupe c'est très bien nagé
elle peut mettre même même être la dette
plusieurs minutes sous l'eau jérôme et
au pied comme le fut son père sa mission
réguler les populations de taupe ce
petit mammifère de quelques centimètres
de long fait en effet le malheur des
jardiniers comme ici dans le parc du
château de versailles
donc là vous voyez la toba attaqué à la
creuse est pratiquement trentaine de
mètres là dans la nuit on est devant le
petit trianon
donc on peut pas laisser une pelouse
comme ça saccagé le petit trianon et
cette demeure coquette où
marie-antoinette émettant se replier
aujourd'hui pour conserver l'harmonie du
paysage qui lui fait face
jérôme posent tous les quinze jours des
pièges à tokyo
là on trouve deux galeries il ya
toujours deux galeries l arrivée ici
elle a poussé la terre et elle continue
donc là je vais mais deux pièges il se
sert de cet outil en acier cuivré appelé
piège putanges une méthode mécanique et
écologique qu utilisaient déjà andré le
nôtre le jardinier de louis xiv
jérôme l'a relancé il ya une dizaine
d'années et voici le résultat
et voilà que là on a une petite femelle
elle a bien été prise juste derrière la
tête donc la passion faire c'est parfait
découvrons l'animal à l'état vivant par
chance jérôme a réussi à en capturer une
le matin du tournage c'est parti pour
une séance d'exercice ben on va voir je
vous montrais à la toque manche pour 90%
de vers de terre
donc elle est capable de manger
pratiquement son poids par jour en vers
de terre et elle est capable de
s'enterrer en quelques secondes la
finaux de préfère s'enfuir sous la terre
oui l'épreuve de natation s'avère plus
réussis
comptant 5000 à 10000 individus la
population de taupe du parc de
versailles croire grâce au recul des
produits chimiques
seuls 300 d'entre elles sont supprimés
chaque année fin de ce 7 8 le journal
rendez vous demain pour une nouvelle
édition bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]